- [Instructor] So I have this number here,
and what I would you to do is
pause this video and tell me
for this number, how
many hundreds do we have,
how many tens, and how many ones?
Pause this video and
try to think about it.
(bell dings)
All right, well, we can just look
at each of the place values.
And we can start in either direction,
but let's start on the right side.
So if we start on the right,
we look at the ones place right over here,
and this tells us that we have two ones.
So we could write that right over there.
And then we go to the next place value.
We go one place to the left.
We go to the tens place.
This tells us how many
tens we are dealing with.
And this is four tens.
So we'd write that like that.
And then last but not least,
if we go one more place to the left,
this is the hundreds place,
and so we have eight hundreds.
So this number, which is 842,
it's the same thing as eight hundreds,
plus four tens, plus two ones.
Or another way to think about it is
you could view it as 800,
plus four tens is the same thing as 40,
plus two ones is the same thing as two.
So these are different ways of
representing the same number.
Now, what I just did up here,
this is known as a place value table,
which we will be discussing many times
as we start building our
understanding of place value.
So it's good to know what
people are talking about
when they say, "Place value table."
So let's just do one more example.
Let's say that we had
the following number.
So this number right over here.
And let's put that into a
place value table as well.
So how many hundreds am I
dealing with, how many tens,
and then how many ones?
Pause this video again and see
if you can figure that out.
Fill out this place value table.
All right, well, we can see
that this is the number of hundreds,
this is the number of tens,
'cause that's the tens place,
and this is the number of ones.
The ones place, tens
place, hundreds place.
And so if we start at the left this time,
we have five hundreds.
We see that right over there.
We actually, and this one's
an interesting example,
we have zero tens.
So we'll just put a zero right over there.
And we have seven ones, so we
put a seven right over there.